what i think the issue is as kovid is
receding as an excuse for uh cultural
and social control and political control
both by media outlets and governments
they need a new excuse
in order to have you know total
domination over people's lives and it's
going to be really hard to find one
because a pandemic makes sense this is
something that affects literally
everyone this is something where you can
only have quite limited control in terms
of how it spreads it's a virus quite
literally it goes viral um but if you're
gonna pivot from that to
kind of white supremacy
first of all that's less tangible second
of all
the number of people who identify as
white supremacist is virtually nil and
it's very hard to
to tell these truckers for example who
were like you know i don't believe in
these mandates well the only reason you
care about that is white supremacy it's
like well the white supremacy is i'm
driving through the snow and putting my
life in danger all the time because this
is the most dangerous job on earth so
it's they don't know where to pivot from
uh you know the last couple of years
where they've had a great excuse to
completely control every aspect of
people's lives so there's a degree of
anxiety that needs to be broadcast
and correct if you're unable to keep
that with one very large warhead you
need multiple smaller ones to try and
contribute to it but which it's but it's
nowhere near as effective i mean it's
one thing to kind of you know new
hiroshima it's nothing to be a sniper
it's just like sure the sniper is going
to make people scared but it's nowhere
near as unconditional surrender dude
i've just thought of something so you
know how a lot of the time people get
one of the concerns that you have from
more libertarian or conservative type
people is that during a crisis the
government is then going to overstep and
a lot of the rights that they seize from
you during this time of emergency ones
that you don't get back
what it sounds like you're saying here
is that there is an equivalent with the
media that the media raise the water
level of the neuroticism the anxiety the
ambient anxiety that pervades through
everything uh and sort of the volume of
vitriol that is in the press
and they also
aren't keen
about correct allowing us this is such a
[ __ ] interesting model to think about
the media are much worse than the
governments and and we know this because
let's suppose i was a democratic
governor or a labor minister whatever in
the uk
and i looked at the data and i said wait
a minute there's nothing behind this
social distancing this is nonstop like
where's the six feet coming from how the
hell is that going to prevent anything
and okay theoretically you're saying
it's going to prevent it well it's not
working because you know we had social
distinct code would still spread
everywhere
if i said this on television i'd be out
of office
because
immediately every outlet from left to
right would be like uh you know shadow
minister malice
doesn't says social distinct doesn't
work he wants us to oh he clearly wants
us to die he's not following the science
this guy's a lunatic why is he opening
his mouth look at all these people
saying this if social and side note if
social this thing was efficacious why
are we bringing it back and if we're not
bringing it back why do we do to begin
with that's a separate note but i would
not be in a position
as a politician to question this and we
know this because you know people call
gavin newsom who is the governor here of
california who was caught having dinner
while socialistic rules were in effect
and there are many other such cases
where you know politicians were just
basically being hypocrites
they knew but in their defense what were
they supposed to do
they they had no choice but to follow
this drumbeat as you were saying of
ambient anxiety
dude that's such a good
concept to keep in mind
that this is what conservatives get
wrong conservatives are think that the
enemy or uh the labor party or the
democrats here and we're gonna kick joe
biden out of office or we're gonna be
jeremy corbyn blah blah
that that's not the issue when you have
jeremy corbyn is the tail joe biden is
the tail the corporate press are the dog
who are wagging that tail
[ __ ] man i'm not gonna be able to get
that out of my head but it's you cannot
see it another example i used a couple
years ago was let's suppose i'm a
democratic politician and i think trump
is dividing america i think he's
completely either a racist or he's uh
fuming the fuels of racism to further
his agenda and i think he's an ass and i
think he's an educated and think he's
boorish i think he has no business being
in the white house but i don't think he
should be impeached or removed from
office from a dopey phone call where he
was fishing for something that the
impeachment has no one's been rude from
office before uh this is does not reach
that level
i can't as a democrat go in front of my
constituents who heard four years of
russia russia russia and trump
collusion and keep my seat
i did not have that freedom so it's very
clear
who's in charge of whom dude
do you follow am i wrong no you're not
and it's it's just when you see
something that ties all of the threads
together that's like a common
uh a single concept like that that the
goal of the press is to keep the volume
high that's actually what they're trying
to achieve and it explains why so many
topics recently have been overblown when
you see like why the [ __ ] endless
endless stories in mainstream media
about rogan about who he's had on the
show or about what he said in the past
or about whatever and then reactions to
the reactions and then has the the white
house said something
all the canadian truckers or just pick
whatever it is because you're right you
know if you've got a huge huge vat of
anxiety to fill and the pandemic starts
to slowly get lifted out of that
so the
the question that i have that i always
come back to and it's the one that i
keep on asking you about is
what is the end goal is it just that
greater fear brings greater control
it gives you power it gives you strength
it gives you money and it gives you a
status because now everyone's looking at
me to make decisions uh so that's good
for my ego and my
status and it also
uh for many of the audience it
rationalizes their um
mental disquiet uh now because they're
they're filling a need as well so
they're not only creating a need they're
also filling a need
among you know educated urban uh wealthy
people who are kind of disquieted by
their nature what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace